this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer ok I didn't think
I would need to make this video but
people are burning down valuable
infrastructure out of fear for their
health I'm sure you have heard all the
insane theories 5g towers are weakening
the immune system and causing the global
pandemic 5g is causing cancer 5g is mind
control by the lizard people I don't
think I will succeed in convincing many
of the lunatics that believe these
things so I'm not going to try but let's
explore what 5g actually is how it works
and some of its real problems today
we're going to learn some interesting
things about data transmission science
and learn how our ability to transfer
data through the air has evolved over
the past four decades hopefully we can
pull a few of the people on the fence
over to the side we're rational people
live in the process we have been using
different wavelengths of electromagnetic
radiation to transmit information for
hundreds of years in ancient Greece they
use signal fires to convey messages with
visible light today we send messages
with light through fiber-optic cables
these cables are capable of carrying
insane quantities of information and are
the bedrock of the Internet but we can't
connect all devices to it because many
devices need to be wireless to make
wireless data transmission possible
cellular networks needed to be developed
and it all started here in Japan in 1979
with the first generation cellular
network which we now call 1g it began in
Tokyo where high-power radio towers
would communicate directly with phones
installed and caris these towers used
radio waves with frequencies sitting
around here on the electromagnetic
spectrum and simply transferred the data
in analog let's see how analog data can
be transmitted using a carrier frequency
say we want to send a sound wave a
simple sine wave of 100 Hertz we want to
apply it to an 850 megahertz wave a wave
with significantly higher frequency
we can do this with amplitude modulation
or frequency modulation AM and FM you
have definitely heard of these terms
before with radio stations a.m. applies
the data to the amplitude of the carrier
frequency so it will vary the amplitude
of the carrier frequency like so
basically tracing the original wave with
its peaks and troughs FM applies to data
to the frequency of the carrier wave
like so varying the distance between
Peaks to trace the original wave to
transfer a call using this method you
need a dedicated frequency band defined
by the lowest and highest frequencies
used if another user is using that
frequency band on the same tower then
you need to use a different frequency
band the more frequency bands you have
the more calls the tower can handle this
is bandwidth as the number of users grew
the system's capabilities were
continually been stretched adding more
frequencies to grow bandwidth is an
option but adding frequencies comes with
its difficulties frequencies need to be
licensed and there is a lot of
competition weather radar military
communication and security systems GPS
television broadcasts radio stations
radio astronomy aviation systems and air
traffic control they all need their own
frequency bands in order to gain new
frequency bands companies often had to
go to auction and purchased the license
with huge capital investment this was
done with every new generation of cell
network but a lot was done to cram more
data onto a single frequency band
through the years increasing the number
of users that can use the same frequency
band can be as simple as increasing the
number of towers instead of using a
single high power tower to cover an
entire city multiple lower power towers
could be used frequency bands could then
be assigned to individual customers
within each towers range without
interfering with the same band in
neighboring cells this increased the
number of users networks could support
but it did not increase the data
transfer rates at its best one G was
capable of 2.4 kilobits per second but
describing it in bits is a
best counterintuitive because as we said
it worked in analog bits were the units
of digital data 2g assured in a new era
of mobile phones with the introduction
of a fully digital system instead of
encoding an analogue signal into a
frequency band we encoded binary data if
you are like me this was your first
experience with cellular networks my
first phone was this beast
the legendary Nokia 3310 sure it could
make calls but digital data allowed for
a new form of communication
this was the era a new language was born
text speak a language of gibberish
invented to keep within the 160
character limit and prevent your mobile
network provider from charging you for
two texts in English each character in
that 160 character text was encoded with
7 bits
therefore a 160 character text contained
1120 bits when 2 G was first introduced
it could achieve 9.6 kilobits per second
it could handle that 1120 bit text
message with ease but the 2g era lasted
right up to the launch of the first
iPhone and speeds had increased to 200
kilobits per second thanks to improved
internet protocols like general packet
radio switching or GPRS sometimes
referred to as 2.5 G by the time the
iPhone 2 launched 3G was the new hot
topic 3G introduced additional frequency
bands it's estimated that in Europe
alone companies paid over 100 billion
dollars in auctions to gain new
frequencies but 3G also made the change
to a system that fully utilized the
method of data packet switching which
GPRS utilized packet switching allowed
thousands of customers to share many
different frequencies far more
efficiently here data was split into
smaller data packets each data packet
contains a header which contains the
address of the destination and
information on how to reassemble the
data packets splitting the data into
smaller bite-sized chunks allow
to make better use of the frequency
bands available instead of trying to
find a large gap of availability on a
single frequency band we could split the
data into small chunks and send it
across many different frequency bands
the moment is small availability
appeared like changing from sending a
huge truck of data on a single road to
sending thousands of motorcycle
messengers over roads with the least
traffic this made our use of the
frequency bands capacity more efficient
and allowed us to carry more data as
time went on these protocols improved
allowing even more efficient use of the
bandwidth in 2005 high-speed packet
access or HSPA which you have likely
seen represented on your phone as a H+
was introduced which increased speeds up
to 42 megabits per second this was
labeled 3.5 G 4G introduced a new
technology called long term evolution or
LTE it introduced even more frequency
bands like the 700 megahertz band that
was previously used for analog TV
broadcasts it also introduced a new way
of squeezing more data through the
existing frequency bands with orthogonal
frequency-division multiplexing or OFDM
OFDM allowed us to send far more data
you are probably familiar with the idea
of constructive and destructive
interference where two waves meeting can
combine and either enhance or cancel out
the amplitude of each other to prevent
this signals traditionally had to be
separated out over time to prevent
interference but OFDM allowed the
signals to be squeezed together an
overlap allowing the same amount of data
to be sent over a shorter period of time
when the signals arrived they were
separated out and converted to binary
data once again how I don't know magic
or math or something honestly the fact
we can stream HD movies on her phone
without a wired connection should seem
like magic to the average person it has
gotten so advanced that we are now
struggling to increase speeds without
adding new frequencies but
aren't a whole lot available so network
providers are now reaching into the
bargain bin and taking out frequencies
nobody wants to use high-frequency
millimeter waves higher frequency waves
have normally been shunned for these
types of applications higher frequency
waves just earned as good at traveling
they get blocked by practically
everything including rain think of them
like visible ice unless you have a
direct line of sight with the torch you
can't see it to deal with this network
providers need to install huge numbers
of transmitters studies have estimated
that to bring 100 megabit per second
download speeds to 72 percent population
coverage and one gigabit per second
speeds to 55 percent of the u.s.
population about 13 million
utility pole mounted 28 gigahertz base
stations would be needed at a cost of
400 billion dollars having this many
base stations will help relieve
congestion over a single frequency band
but 5g will also be using something
called massive MIMO or massive
multiple-input multiple-output
these are basically just groups of
antenna that are listening and
broadcasting to the same frequency bands
this would cause interference but 5g is
also looking to use beamforming which
will allow the antenna to aim at your
phone instead of broadcasting the signal
in all directions this coupled with the
fact that higher frequency waves can
carry more data means 5g is reaching
speeds of up to 1,800 megabits per
second in the u.s. higher frequencies
can carry more information because we
are encoding our information into the
wave cycles our measure of frequency is
hertz but all one hertz really means is
that one wave cycle is reaching us per
second 10 Hertz means 10 wave cycles are
reaching us per second and 190 mega
Hertz means 190 million wave cycles are
reaching us for a second because we are
encoding our information into the wave
cycles that means we can encode more
information into higher frequency waves
up until now we've been using
frequencies between 700 megahertz and
2500 megahertz so 700 million wave
cycles per second to two thousand five
hundred million wave cycles per second
5g will allow higher download speeds and
lower latency this will be huge for time
critical technologies like self-driving
cars that require rapid communication
between vehicles in the network and
allow even more devices to join the
network to create the Internet of Things
5g has a lot of potential and no it's
not dangerous the electromagnetic
spectrum starts on the far left with
gamma radiation which has very high
frequency and short wavelengths higher
frequencies and shorter wavelengths
equates to higher energy and indeed
gamma radiation does cause cancer
anything over here you need to worry
about but 5g is operating all the way
over here towards the lower energy
frequencies yes pass visible ice which
last time I checked no one is afraid of
yes like visible ice and microwaves it's
possible to cause heating with high
enough powered beams of these
wavelengths this is the only non
crackpot theory I can find on 5g that
actually sits in the realm of
plausibility the military even used
high-powered 95 gigahertz beams in their
Active Denial system which just made the
people on the receiving end feel like
someone just opened an oven door in
front of their face and it could burn
people if exposed for long enough it's
uncomfortable and was intended to
disperse crowds this was essentially a
focused beam of 95 gigahertz light akin
to a massive magnifying glass focusing
lights to burn a piece of paper because
yes just as visible light can be used to
cause heating so can these wavelengths
when used in high enough power and
intensity as we said earlier these
frequencies are blocked by rain and so
they certainly can't penetrate your skin
and these transmitters simply don't have
the power to cause heating that would be
damaging they are simply too low power
and there are plenty of studies that
show that they are not harmful if you
are afraid of 5g in this way you
as well be afraid of streetlights
because they emit higher energy
frequencies everyday technologies like
this can seem like magic until you peel
back the layers to their earliest
iteration and see that they are just the
product of many years of problem-solving
with each successive generation adding
more complexity if you'd like to learn
more about the whole electromagnetic
spectrum including which parts are
dangerous and which aren't
you should check out brilliants course
that unravels the physics of waves and
lies inside you'll learn things like how
light can exhibit both particle-like and
wave-like behaviors how much energy
electromagnetic radiation can carry and
even how to measure the speed of light
you can set a goal to improve yourself
and then work at that goal a little bit
every day brilliant makes that easy with
interactive explorations and a mobile
app that you can take with you wherever
you are if you are naturally curious
want to build your problem-solving
skills or need to develop confidence in
your analytical abilities then get
brilliant premium to learn something new
every day brilliant thought provoking
math science and computer science
content helps guide you to mastery by
taking complex concepts and breaking
them up into bite-sized understandable
chunks you'll start by having fun with
interactive explorations and over time
you'll be amazed with what you
accomplished as always thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter discord server and reddit Ereb
below
you